la calle de John acordonada por la
policía ubicada en el distrito diez de
París alberga un centro comunitario
kurdo fue allí en pleno día donde un
individuo abrió fuego el restaurante y
la peluquería vecinos también kurdos
fueron atacados
vimos gente corriendo y luego entramos
en la peluquería y vimos que había tres
heridos en la peluquería entonces me
pidieron que llamara a los bomberos
el presunto autor de 69 años ya era
conocido por la policía en particular
por un ataque contra inmigrantes así lo
ha confirmado la fiscal de París en el
lugar de los hechos
se trata de personas que estaban
instaladas en tiendas de campaña y la
persona en cuestión atacó estas tiendas
se abrió una investigación a finales de
2021 y la persona en cuestión ha sido
puesta en libertad recientemente
herido sobre todo en la cara el
sospechoso fue trasladado al hospital en
estado de relativa urgencia acto seguido
fue detenido la brigada criminal se hizo
cargo de la investigación fue un acto
racista Las investigaciones tendrán que
decirlo una cosa es cierta Esta es una
de las líneas de la investigación
[Aplausos]
iracunda por el ataque la comunidad
kurda de París reaccionó